we're joined now by one of the two
congressmen who made a so-called
unauthorized visit to kabul this week
seth moulton he's a democrat and he went
there with one of his republican
colleagues congressman moulton is a
member of the house armed services
committee and served four tours in iraq
with the u.s marines congressman good
morning to you
and thank you for your service on a
morning where we're reminded of what's
at stake thanks tony i want to begin
with your reaction to 13 dead service
members in afghanistan
yesterday i mean it's absolutely
devastating
and and i want i i want people to
understand
what they were doing
because it's one of the most heroic
things i've ever seen in my life
out there at abbey gate i expected to
see marines on one side of the gate and
afghans on another
but that doesn't work
because those marines have to go out in
in literally sift through the sea of
humanity of people so desperate to get
out that they're back there today
despite the bombings just to get out
from the taliban
and so you have young
marines out there physically close
feet from the taliban with their whips
yeah
to put little afghan girls
on their backs
hold
afghan women by their hands in in
and pull them to freedom
the security situation there is bizarre
because you've got the taliban who we
were bombing a month ago now doing the
initial security check
for the airport where our troops are
there was a failure there that's how
this bombing got through can this
continue
i mean it's such a cruel irony that
the terrorist group that harbored the
911 attackers
we now have to work with them
to sort through the people who are
trying to get to freedom but there's no
elegant way though congressman to end a
war is there something that should
clearly there is it could or should have
been done differently yeah there's
something you believe it had to go down
this way no it did not chaotic as it is
and let's be clear this failure is not
the troops on the ground
the failure is with us in washington
because all we had to do was start this
evacuation earlier
and we've been pushing the
administration to do this for months all
we needed to do is start the evacuation
earlier because people were getting
evacuated through afghanistan by just
showing up at the embassy like they do
at any other embassy in the world but it
wasn't going fast enough but congressman
i keep hearing nobody expected the
afghan troops to buckle the way they did
with all the training and all the money
i think from the u.s position and i
don't know you certainly know more than
i do on this
everybody thought that the afghan army
can handle this
no yeah that's true but that's not an
excuse for not starting the evacuation
earlier yeah there's no reason why we
couldn't we couldn't do this and then
not put these
young marines in this position i mean
let me just share first you know i've
talked to these guys out there
you know 18 year old lance corporal says
to me
you know so it's pretty tough
when
you get asked
to separate a family because someone
doesn't qualify because their older
sister
is is 19 and doesn't qualify as a
dependent so then i have to take her
hand and
walk her back
to the taliban
while the rest of her family goes to
america that's what we're asking of
these kids
congressman i want to ask you about the
taliban tony mention them being
responsible for security uh we've
learned that u.s officials in kabul gave
the taliban a list of u.s citizens green
card holders uh senator bob menendez is
saying you can't trust the taliban
senator ben sasse is calling it a kill
list what's your reaction well of course
we can't trust the taliban but this
again is a situation
that decision makers in washington have
put these officials on the ground the
only way we can get these american
citizens through the taliban lines
is to tell them who they are now i don't
know we could have to go into the
details of whether we should have really
been giving names or whether there was
some other way to just assure that they
had the right passports
but that's how desperate the situation
is right now you caused a bit of a
controversy when you went without
authorization why did you do that and
what were you looking for
you know
the week before
i've been trying i've stayed up all
night one night just to get four
families through the lives four
four young families
sending hundreds and hundreds of text
messages between the afghans some of
their other friends and in troops that i
happen to know at the base
saying to the the my kids are crying
they don't have enough water we need to
go home no stay there stay there a
little bit longer i've got someone who
knows where you are i'm testing them
grids and showing the pictures of where
they are outside the basin and at the
end of the night after staying up all
night doing this i got one one
of the four families out
when i saw a picture of them
a heroic journalist
his wife and two daughters about the
same age as mine i said
you know what it's worth it
and if i can get on here you went
without if i can get on a plane you're
thinking if i can get on a plane
[Music]
and save a few more lives
[Music]
then then absolutely i'll do that and by
being there i was able to do that there
were several families that
that we got over
just by being there by being because the
pentagon's perspective is different on
this point uh john kirby the
spokesperson for the pentagon said that
that you and your fellow congressmen
they certainly took time away from what
we had been doing that day when you were
there and they were saving lives you
being there they're saying it it made it
harder it probably took time away from
john kirby but i don't care what people
in washington say
the people on the ground i mean
literally were hugging me
thanking me for coming
because america needs to know
what's going on there and i've been in
that position i was a marine in iraq
when i felt abandoned by congress
because people in washington
were making decisions that
they cost that effect lives that cost
lives
and they didn't know what was going on
in the ground they didn't know
what was happening there and i vowed
that if i ever get to congress
i'm not going to leave the troops behind
you learn something there that the
people in washington don't know several
things several things we've already
shared
for example all these refugees are now
going to to refugee camps where they
don't have enough food and water because
administration lawyers are preventing
donations i learned that as much as as a
veteran in congress i wanted to extend
the august 31st deadline in fact i
thought that being there on the ground
would be the best place to advocate for
that
that
because of this crazy relationship we
have with the taliban we can't afford to
do that so
we learned a lot but the single most
important thing i learned is what
what unbelievable heroes these young
americans are we are also
congressman i've never been more proud
to be an american thank you very much
connor
all right